when bond scott was alive he's with acdc
you were a guy in a band called the
gordies
jordy jordy is that how you said it you
know it was an obscure kind of band
right
they weren't doing all that well and you
had even said you were
almost at the point where you had no
money you were living with your parents
you were in your 20s
i'd say 30s at your 30s you're living at
home yeah you were living with your
parents
you were living you were living with
your parents and you'd even said you
know i'm going to give it another couple
of weeks but if it doesn't work out
that's right i'm going to open an
automotive business which i did
you did well how do you go from the
jordies to ac dc bond scott dies who
knew to call you from ac dc when uh
old bond went first of all there was a
fan from cleveland
to my eternal debt uh i think
um mutt langer who kept saying listen
mutt lang
lang he said you've got to try this guy
and
bond scott himself unwittingly told the
boys he said while a rock singer has a
scene in england
there's this kid called brian johnson
who played with the when he was in
the the other band and we we played
together and we got on well me and bond
we just had a painting we went with
separate wheels and i never saw him
again but that's very generous of him to
go
very some lead singers would be
possessive and not mention the good news
singer you know
i think he had a gig you know right he
was secure yeah but he just
you know it was a very nice thing to say
so they put the three together and said
we've got to find this guy so i got the
telephone call in the office and this
woman said
um johnson yeah
and i went who's this one that i cannot
say
before because i'm phoning for you must
to come to sing in london
it was a german woman yeah yeah and i
said top secret
i said well for which band i cannot tell
you this
i said but well i'm not coming down the
line
she called you for the audition and says
i cannot tell you
or nothing i said well you're going to
give us a clue she went okay
the initials are ac on ctc and i said so
it's essay
stage when i said too much
[Laughter]
you auditioned in front of the other
guys right yeah well i was still wasn't
going to go down i still
worried about this news i said you know
listen i'm 32 i'm passed myself i did
for rock
[Laughter]
you knew that that was a good page well
it was a good thing but you got to
remember the boys were like a cult
following you know had a cult following
that's true they played they played
college tv
and you know and everybody loved them
but you know they weren't as big
because they blew up after your album uh
back and forth yeah but everybody loved
them and they were just breaking in
america and everywhere
and just after that call 30 minutes
later i got a call from a guy
and he says brian remember me and i said
sure me well i'm doing jingles now would
you sing on a hoover advert
how much and he said 350 quid he said
with residuals and i said i've come down
and
and i went down and i thrown up the boys
i said i'll come down and do it on the
same day so
i went in and did this the new
high-powered hoop mover from hoover
it's a beautiful mover it's 350 pounds
right and then from there i remember
coming out the studio and
just saying gosh it's getting late i
have to get back to newcastle
which is you know five six hour drive in
there
or do i walk across that street to
vanilla studios
that's right you on the one hand you had
to get back to your parents basement uh
but i made a fearful decision that
evening i just said bollocks i'm going
to walk across the street and i did
thank goodness and i opened the door and
there was four guys
sitting on chairs with the big marshall
amps behind them
looking quite miserable because they've
been waiting for us you know
and i came and i said guys i'm and they
said are you are you brian from
newcastle i said i am the one
and i never get malcolm god bless his
cotton socks
came over and he gave us a bottle of
newcastle browneau uh-huh
he said there you go me son and now
you're late i said mate i could kill
this
and i drank it was sang and cleared so
you drank
you drank you got a little loaded and
then you started one
of them you must be kidding when you
so you start to drink with the boys you
bond with the boys and do they start
playing ac dc songs
uh we did do you said uh he said what do
you want to do and i said
well you know nut bush city limits and
they said what
i said i like that song city limits
yeah yeah and mouse says yeah i think i
can do that maybe i'll just give it a
little shot in there you know
and i played a few chords you know yeah
and then i started rocking it i started
singing i got goosebumps there got
i started going away and everybody
suddenly suddenly started thinking
what's maybe we've got something here
what's happening here and so did they
hire you on the spot they said
or did they play the game with you oh
once you go home we'll think about it
and uh or did they say look this is no
it was what happened was i said thanks
very much lads for
this thing i said we'll get back to my
man they're not gonna believe i sang
with you guys and
but thanks very much you know when where
you're going i said i gotta get home and
i gotta open the shop up in the morning
that's right you can't leave right i
said why not
i said i've really got to go and they
said so the manager
cheers this out i was going bye-bye lads
thank you name again
the [ __ ] so you get into ac dc
and you get in the studio and how long
does it take you to record six weeks
six weeks for the entire album six weeks
for the entire world
isn't that the magic play together they
don't sometimes it's it's just
get in there just get in there and do it
it was the probably the most magical
time in my life i knew something was
happening but it was happening so
quick i couldn't grasp it could you
grasp that this was going to be a huge
album
absolutely not no i i just know one
thing the first song i had to write was
uh shook me all night long
wow and um i remember sitting there you
know i mean this is when my passion with
cars comes in the first lane i wrote was
she was a fast machine she kept the
motor clean
she was the best damn woman and i went
i'm writing them with cars again
right and i'll give it a mile next
morning he's gonna yeah are you writing
about cats
and i said quite cockily the next day
after i'd heard it the first rough mix
and i was sitting because we just had a
little cassette player in this little
house we had and
yeah and then the next morning that mile
put it on again he said i'm gonna
listen to this again mine in there when
i sat and i just went
you know i think that's about the best
rock and roll song i think i've ever
heard in my life
but what i said i'm telling you i think
that's the best
you feel a little crazy saying that
because you know because that was the
new boy
i said and mouse said you could be right
mate